-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We are here with Maude Apatow.
You can tell,
from the audience reaction,
whenever I mention
the show "Euphoria,"
this has
a very fervent fan base.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is it fun to be
a part of something
that people are
paying so much attention to?
-It's so crazy.
I can't even believe it.
Like, I just -- Every day,
I'm, like, on Instagram,
and people make
these super-intricate
edits and drawings,
and, like, it's so amazing.
So, yeah, thank you, guys.
-Have you had --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, obviously,
you have your professional life
on camera.
With your downtime,
I know that you like to --
and celebrate
the reality-show world.
-Yes. I really do.
-Yeah.
-You went to the
"The Bachelor" mansion.
-I did go to
And Colton photobombed me.
-Really?
-Like, that wasn't even inten--
He just jumped in the back.
I didn't even realize.
-You were just taking a photo
without knowing that
Colton was there?
-But I'm so obsessed
with reality TV,
I went to "The Bachelor" mansion
and sat in the control room
for a rose ceremony, and it was
the coolest thing ever.
-Wow!
-But -- Yeah.
-Is it super-tense?
Is there a lot of chatter
in the control room
during a rose ceremony?
-Oh, yeah, so much more.
And I was just, like,
loving every second.
It was, like, more fun to be
in the control room --
-Well, 'cause I would imagine,
in that case,
you've got, like, tight cameras
on, like, all the faces.
-Yeah.
They're talking about them,
and it's so --
Yeah, it was crazy.
But I'm a big
"90 Day Fiancé" fan.
-Okay, great.
-That's my favorite.
-And do any -- Have, like --
Have you connected with any of
the 90-day fiancés?
-This is my
most horrible trait, is, like --
So, like, the other week,
we were, like,
celebrating "Euphoria," and I --
I'll have like one drink,
and then I think
it's a great idea for me
to message the "90 Day Fiancé"
cast on Instagram.
Every time. So --
-And what sort of messages
do you send them, Maude?
-I just hope they're okay.
-Okay.
-Like, I just get so worried
and, like, stressed,
and I'll be watching it
and I'm, like, kind of drunk
and I'll just be like,
"Oh, no, I need to check in."
Like, I know this
was shot like -- what? --
four months before.
Like, I just need to maybe check
and see how they're doing.
-And do you hear back from them?
-Sometimes, but mostly not.
-Okay.
Well, they're all very busy,
and, you know,
they have these
new fiancés, yeah.
-They know I care, so -- Yeah.
-I hate to put you on the spot,
but I'm just going to be honest.
How does that show work?
-"90 Day Fiancé"?
-Yeah.
-You have, um -- Whoa!
I've -- Whoa!
I've been waiting
for this moment.
No.
-I really like
making people plug shows
they have nothing to do with.
-You have one person
who's from America
and then one person
from another country.
And the person from whatever
country they're from
is in America
on the spousal visa.
So they have
90 days to get married
or they have to go back to
wherever they're from.
-So the show basically
puts them with a stranger.
-Yes -- Or no, no, no.
Sometimes,
they meet online before.
-Oh, gotcha. So it's not --
-Yeah, yeah. It depends.
Each situation is different.
-Okay. And what percentage
is it working out on
old "90 Day Fiancé"?
-There are some really --
There's ones that have
really worked out.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah.
-But, like,
what percentage, Maude?
What are we talking? Like 5?
-Oh, my gosh.
No, more than that.
More than that.
You have some
soul mates on there.
-Really?
-Yes.
-This is wonderful to hear.
I'm happy, because it doesn't
sound like it should work.
-It varies.
-Yeah.
-I've only watched --
I'm just going to come clean.
I watch "Love is Blind."
Have you watched
"Love is Blind"?
-Yes, yes.
-Yeah.
-Not this season.
-Yeah, there's a new season,
which my wife and I
are trying to decide if
we're going to put ourselves
through it again.
-And they have a
"Love is Blind: Japan."
-Do they really?
-Yeah, I saw on Netflix
the other day.
I was like, "Got to watch that."
-That's great.
I mean, it does transfer
pretty easy to other cultures.
I mean, I feel like
everybody understands it.
It's like, you're going to
fall in love by a voice.
-Right, right.
-Like, got it. Sign up.
And what about "The Bachelor"?
Do you feel like,
when you watch that,
are you mostly rooting for
true love?
-I mean, of course.
-Yeah. Okay.
-Are you?
-I'm kinda -- Well, alright.
-No?!
-Well, there's
a disaster element of it
that I feel like
makes for good TV.
-But then it all, like,
is so nice when it works out.
-You are --
You're built for this.
You're the perfect audience.
-I'm such a sucker.
I'm, like, always crying.
They're, like, riding horses
and, like
-Well, that's when I realized
I had to step back.
Like, first, I had to step back
because I'm like,
"Oh, I'm enjoying this too much,
like, watching these people
with their
messy lives interact,"
and I felt bad about myself
as a person.
But then I realized
I had to step back
because I'm like, "Also,
I'm more invested in their love
than I am in any of
the friends and family
and I'm fully crying about these
people that I've never met,
and I think
that this is unhealthy."
-No, I can relate to that.
That's why I message them.
I care so much.
And, also, I always am
messaging people.
Like, I'll watch, like,
a random Netflix docu-series,
and, like, some random person
who's doing an interview --
I'll find them on Instagram
and be like,
"Hope everything's
going alright."
-By the way, I just want to
celebrate the fact that
I think I've never met anyone
who uses social media
just to, like,
check in on people.
-No, like, my, like,
"You up?" text is, like,
sliding into a "90 Day Fiancé"
cast member's DMs,
asking if everything's okay.
-It's really great.
I like to think that the
"90 Day Fiancé" --
when they have
their reunion thing,
they just talk about you.
They're like, "Are you getting
these weird texts?"
-This weird girl. Yeah.
-"You know this girl from
'Euphoria'?
Is she asking you
if you're okay all the time?"
It's like, "Yeah, we should ask
her if she's okay."
-Oh, God,
that's so embarrassing.
I'm like,
"Darcey, if you see this --
I always text her, "I love you."
-Oh, that's great.
Darcey, if you see this,
I think the love is real.
And I think you should
stop ignoring it.
Whatever you're looking out
there for in 90 days
is sitting right in this chair.
Hey, Maude, thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you!
-It's such a delight
to have you.
Maude Apatow, everybody.
The season finale of "Euphoria"
airs this Sunday on HBO.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."